they're on to our like our next talk of
this session
um as we see in his um
um
um
he's currently a like an apple privacy
researcher but he has also previously
been
like you know Google researcher any
visits Simon's a lot
um
um
um he does like tons of amazing work in
the Privacy machine learning space and
he will talk today about kind of
memorization and if it's a good or bad I
guess we will learn thank you very
excellent it's always great to be back
at Simon's some of this work has
actually been done with assignments and
part of this work we're done with my
collaborator Chung who is a Google
research
so uh this work the basic theme of this
work and basic question we address in
this work is about is kind of
fundamental question of the role of
memorization in generalization and
learning more generally but it does have
uh some
uh strong motivation and con connections
to privacy and also gives some insights
to to phenomena such as desperate
effects of learning techniques the
learning techniques have on um
uh the accuracy on different subgroups
uh in the data which might be relevant
to uh to the themes of this Workshop
anyway so
as I mentioned we'll be trying to
understand the role of memorization and
the starting point of this work is a
sort of well-known observation that
state-of-the-art deep learning networks
uh tend to fit the training data very
well even when the
tester or their actual accuracy is not
that high for example a typical training
set error is often close to zero or zero
whereas test error could be anywhere
between 10 and 30 percent and what that
implies uh is that uh
in in a way the training algorithm
memorizes in uh the these training
labels that it cannot predict well or or
in a way one can think of it over it's
it seems to overfit to the training data
even though it uh these are some of the
best algorithms and the reason uh this
is uh somewhat surprising is that we
typically learn in uh machine learning
courses uh that machine learning
algorithms are supposed to balance uh
some kind of notion of capacity uh with
the fit to the data so as to know not to
or not to overfit so overfitting or
memorizing a lot of data should be bad
soon uh by now we have a lot of sort of
much better empirical understanding of
this uh phenomena thanks to the sort of
pioneering work of Michael Cooperative
Zhang and his colleagues uh who for
example show the standard learning
algorithms when you feed them a
completely randomly labeled uh training
set for a with million uh examples uh
imagenet will achieve uh training error
of uh just nine percent which is very
low even though the test error it's
completely random labels will will be
close to uh 100.
sorry thanks
by training versus test yes
training
afterwards yes yes that's just
afterwards measured on the test set
which is the pro our proxy for the true
error on the population and training is
just the empirical you're not saying
that the test error is essentially
you're wrong on everything yes yes in
this example your fed random completely
random labels so you're not there is no
hope you will actually learn anything
because your feather a data set which is
kind of useless
training Arabians nine percent the
training error is how well you predict
the set you were trained on the
empirical error so the if you so when
you feed that data set the learning
algorithm actually
outputs a model which fits which
predicts correctly on the training data
on the training data that it was given
almost all of them are predicted
correctly so it kind of fits the data
that was given but doesn't fit the data
it hasn't seen of course
foreign
the authors of this work also point out
that this is a phenomena that is not
well explained by uh existing Theory uh
of machine learning
so and the goal of this work is is to
give an under uh your understanding of
where does uh
why do we see this memorization why does
all this happen but before I can uh
explain let me Define memorization more
formally
and uh for this purpose for the purpose
of this talk memorization will
intuitively capture the notion uh uh we
say that that uh an example in a data
set is memorized if
um
uh this example is fit by the model the
model that when it receives it in a data
set will accurately fit the label on
that example but if you were to remove
that example from the data set the the
model would not be able to predict it
well so in a way it has to in order to
fit that uh
uh that example it has to memorize the
label and more formally
for data set s which will con which will
be an labeled example x i y i and index
I have an example in this data set a
learning algorithm which will denote by
a well you know this memorization of an
algorithm a and data set s and index I
as this difference between these two
terms
all right the first term measures the
sort of the accuracy uh or the
prediction accuracy of the output
hypothesis on delay on the example
itself when given the entire data set
and the reason we look we're looking at
the probability here because most of the
algorithms we're interested in are
randomized and the second term looks at
the accuracy on on that same example
when the example is removed from the
data set again memorization is just the
difference between these terms and we'll
informally say that an example is
memorized them this difference between
these two probabilities is some large
constant say half percent
an important property of this definition
is that it's directly related to to this
so-called generalization gap which is
the difference between digital uh the
true error uh on the Unseen data and the
empirical error and I mean this this is
the expression which says that in
expectation over for every distribution
over the data the expectation over the
data set drawn from the data the average
memorization score is almost exactly
equal uh to the uh again the expectation
of this of the difference between the
through error on the distribution and
the error on the data set this is uh so
culturalization Gap
and uh as I mentioned so so in
particular if one observes it captures
the intuition that if one observes these
large transition gaps then a lot of data
points uh need to be memorized by the
uh learning algorithm according to this
definition
any question you would like to address
is this uh why is it back with us why
would we see why do we see so much
memorization in learning and is it
necessary
in addition to this theoretical uh
fundamental uh question there are
practical reasons to ask this question
that come from privacy concerns
and we know that if we have a data set
which contains some sensitive data
Health Data or financial data and so on
and so forth then outputting a model
that memorizes many labels can post
privacy risks and this is not a
sort of a theoretical concern we now
have a long line of works on so-called
Black Box membership inference attacks
in which
um it is possible to infer whether a
coin is in this data set and not just by
observing the predictions of an
algorithm and we have known that we know
that these techniques have been further
strengthened more recently by Carolina
and all to extract
sensitive information from uh large
language models
so from this point of view of privacy
the question is uh can uh can we sort of
avoid memorization and still have high
accuracy the same accuracy as as before
so uh in terms of
uh uh sort of this is a question I'm not
the first one to think about it there
are quite a bit of work has been
um
uh inspired by by these empirical
observations that I have mentioned uh
perhaps the biggest line of work is
so-called understanding of uh generation
of interpolating methods a method is
called interpolating if it fits the
training data perfectly sort of it is
accurate on all the training data and
this line of work can be traced to a
very old work of covert heart which who
looked at generalization of one nearest
neighbor which is the most sort of
prototypical
um interpolating method it all it fits
all the examples exactly and more
recently I've been uh quite a few Works
which may be at a high level can be
summarized in the following way
interpolation may be harmless in the
sense that we know that many of these
Works demonstrate that interplating
algorithms can achieve almost the same
generalization or even the same
generalization as regular
non-interpolating method they are not
necessarily worse or not much worse
um however from our point of view they
still do not address why question do I
mean is it real is the memorization
actually necessary and we also know that
memorization happens without
interpolation in that example I just
mentioned the error was nine percent it
was still not zero it's not true
interpolation but there is a lot of
memorization that was required to
memorize the other 91 percent of
examples
yeah
uh so uh that's the related work so um
in this work uh we'll give both
theoretic theoretical and empirical uh
evidence or explanations for why
memorization is necessary uh but before
going there let me start with a bit of
intuition it starts uh by looking at
some examples taken from the c510 data
set track classes an actual data set
with some images and these are I
probably can't see those very well but
these are four
examples from of a truck from that data
set in the training set and what's uh
kind of special about those and we have
identified them using the technique I'll
describe later is that these all of
these examples would need to be
memorized to be fit so none of this all
of them are sufficiently different okay
they're also visually very different
from other tracks that uh standard
learning algorithm would not be able to
predict them as trucks without actually
observing uh uh these examples and the
question so so they need to be memorized
in order to be fit the question is this
useful or not
and again using a technique I'll
describe later we will able to
understand whether an example is useful
or not and specifically we're able to
see that uh
this particular example in the training
set was useful uh in uh predicting uh
this example in the test set now as a
truck
so uh if we were to remove this
particular example from the from the
training set we would not be able to
accurately predict on this track in the
Tesla so it is a useful example
uh it it it is not an easy question uh
especially even for much
yes it's a kind of kind of a dump yeah
it's a kind of yes it's like yes it's a
kind of dump truck with its thing race
this does not seem to help predicting
trucks so that's not a useful uh truck
to memorize uh this turns uh to be
useful to uh predict this example in the
test set as a truck maybe uh you can see
but it also has some wheels and finally
this looks like a stamp with a fire
truck uh doesn't seem to be helpful in
predicting other trucks as trucks so you
can see as a whole uh memories this is
indeed the resolution that these
learning algorithms work with so it's
not
it's hard for everybody
um so as you can see the as a whole
memorization of this for example is
useful however there these are all four
very atypical example very different
from other trucks so before without sort
of
with only 5 000 examples of a truck uh
to see it might be uh impossible to to
know which one will turn out to be
useful and in order to be able to uh to
sort of gain the benefits of of uh
predicting the correct ones it may be
necessary to also memorize uh the
incorrect ones just because a priori you
cannot tell which one of these unique
examples is uh going to turn out to be
useful so that's uh at the high level
the question is where do these hard and
rare examples come from and for this
domain intuition is that the natural
data is not homogeneous like our
favorite Dallas and distribution but
actually consists of many diverse
subpopulations
um and for example if we look at the
example of of birds again actual
examples from c410 data sets they
consist of hundreds of different birth
species taking it in different
backgrounds different magnifications
different angles so and many of these
subpopulations are very very different
from each other if all you know about
the world is this 5000 examples of birds
and uh because there are so many as a
population some of the from some of
these the population will only observe
just a single representative there'll be
just a single unique representative uh
and this and these will be from uh this
unique repetitive will typically come
from circulations that have frequency on
the order of one over n this is why you
only observe a single example but these
are still useful to population improving
the accuracy by one over n is useful for
every example
at the same time uh outliers or things
which are really extremely rare and
useless well also you'll see also see
them only once and similarly noisily
labeled examples will also be something
you'll see only once so you might not be
able to tell
if if these applications are
sufficiently the state you might be
unable to tell between the uh examples
from the population on uh with the
frequency on the order of one over n and
outliers and random noise
so uh these are essentially
indistinguishable uh or maybe hard to
tell apart
so we uh so the question is whether we
uh of whether we need to memorize this
unique things which are rare uh is it
depends on on the relative fraction of
this unique uh or these the populations
with relatively low low frequencies are
there many of those then we need to
memorize if there are few then maybe we
don't care
and and the answer to this question of
course depends on on on the distribution
of the subpopulation frequencies
um in our population uh and it has been
informally
mentioned by many practitioners know
that that natural distributions
typically uh follow have so-called long
tail and what they mean informally is
that this rare and infrequent things uh
overall occupy a significant fraction of
a distribution so you cannot ignore that
fraction of distribution and beside this
sort of um
yeah okay full claw or empirical wisdom
there are some actual measurements in
the literature for example Zhu and
others have um uh used additional
annotation which are annotations which
are available in the Sun data set where
they for every
um image they have in addition to its
class they also have the visibility
pattern which which sort of cited is
visible from for example this is the
visibility for a class of buses the
visibility pattern of being sort of
upfront this is the back this is
somewhere abstracted and similarly for
uh for a class of person and then and
then they plot it for these different
visibility patterns they're relative
frequency and this is a plot on a log
log scale of sort of frequency versus uh
sort of in in descending or water and if
you can see as you can see in this log
log scale this is this frequency has a
sort of a negative minus one slope
roughly
and that because that corresponds to the
famous zip distribution uh in which the
frequency of the case most least most
frequent element is proportional to 1
over k
uh that's famously followed by words
frequencies in many languages
and what's important about this
distribution is is that if we look if it
has enough sort of elements more than
the number of elements is more than and
then the relative weight of all the
frequencies uh between 1 over which are
roughly on the order of one over n is at
least one over log T so it's it's a
non-trivial fraction of the distribution
has this relatively
um uh low frequency
uh so uh yeah that's exactly what I uh
was saying so this long tail uh the
frequency of this type uh will occupy
significant uh fraction of the
distribution so we cannot ignore those
so that's the intuition the the natural
distribution have this tail uh and the
important things in this rare things in
this tale are indistinguishable from
hard a typical example yes why uh why
not
care about things that have weight much
less than what I've read like one of Red
Square
because uh also yes let's say you uh
yeah right good good question so um
let's say you have a population of uh
one over N squared then even if you have
a single representative from each of
those applications you'll have a
populations and some populations like
this at most and the total weight of
this applications which will be
represented by such example will be one
over n you see it's not going to affect
your accuracy yeah it's not basically
the question yes the things which are on
the order of what and if if for every
example you are gaining on the order of
one over n then
the total fraction of these examples
will roughly correspond to the total
gain up to a conversion the total gain
in the in the accuracy final accuracy so
we care specifically about those
um so that's a completely sort of a high
level intuition let me um
show that this can be captured
relatively easily uh by a theoretical
model of learning a very general one on
one hand but very much simplified on the
other hand just to make sure we can
capture this very simple phenomenon
or not so simple but uh
uh this specific phenomenon and in this
basic model we'll have a discrete domain
a capital x of size t uh and set of
labels Y where PSI T is will be the
number of subpopulation and a more
General model and you know paper you can
find a general model each of those
discrete elements will actually
represent at an entire subpopulation but
here in this simple one is just a single
element indivisible one
and we'll Define a learning Problem by a
method distribution over data
distributions five meta distribution
five
typically we think of which typica we're
more used to this worst case learning
models but
representing and learning using a
problem using meta distribution is much
more natural if you want to capture some
prior information that you have about uh
the data distribution you know something
about it
um and the goal will be this the usual
one the goal of learning will be to
minimize uh the uh the true error but
now the true error will be measured uh
not in the worst case but in expectation
over data problem data distribution T
um
sampled from
this meta distribution Phi and of course
the data set sampled IID from this data
distribution and the
hypothesis output by the Learning
algorithms so this is the the goal is to
minimize this average error on a meta
distribution fight by an algorithm a so
now the uh you know our model or the
goal is to
capture that we know something about uh
the the distribution the distribution of
the frequency it has to be long uh has
to be this some kind of long tail
distribution and specifically we'll have
a we'll express it using some kind of
Prior Pi which which is just different
frequency you can think of as just also
a distribution over frequency well we'll
assume that the frequencies of elements
them themselves have a distribution like
a zip distribution you can think of it
as being specified just during using
just two different frequencies the
entire distribution and how will we
Define a learning problem with a prior
like this basically we'll assume that
aside from knowing
that the frequency follow this this
prior we don't know anything about this
about the actual frequencies of the
elements
specifically for each X in the domain X
we'll pick randomly and independently a
frequency povert of that element
from
uh from among these two different
frequencies from our prior and then
because we want the distribution in the
end we'll renormalize everything to be
one
and independencies makes the analysis
much easier you can also think of it as
just effectively just permuting this
randomly this frequencies and assigning
but independently again analy analysis
becomes easier without
much other changes so now this is how
this is how this is the way we'll Define
sort of the distribution of our Dom or
our domain by picking these frequencies
of a certain shape randomly we'll also
assume that there is some kind of
distribution F over labeling function so
we're functions if we're learning here
we could we could as well assume instead
of a distribution we could have taken
the worst case
uh notion but it doesn't matter we'll
stick for Simplicity with also a
distribution over labeling function and
our meta problem 5 with forests prior
over the frequencies and uh say prior
over labeling functions will looks as
false we'll pick the distribution of our
domain according to this process that
I've described where frequencies are
picked randomly and we'll pick a random
labeling function from the from this
distribution of relating functions and
that defines a problem distribution
uh so for this model of learning in this
generality we prove the following
theorem which basically states that uh
if you do not fit examples that are uh
occur once from this discrete domains
you will be sub-optimal and more
formally it says this the expected error
this is the notion that we're trying to
minimize over again choice of problem
data set and hypothesis is
at least the optimum over all algorithms
this is the best achievable information
theoretically
or uh by any algorithm
plus this term which has the style I'll
explain and this is the expected error
so this is the minimum this is the
number examples that occur once in the
data set s but the algorithm doesn't fit
so sub-optimality is lower bounded by
the number of examples you don't fit
multiply again the expectation of this
number time times this conversion factor
Tau which is the price of not fitting
the examples
and what's important about the stuff we
know its exact expression it depends
only on the frequency prior pi and the
data set
and
the data set size 10 so the sample size
and what's not hard to show about this
expression is that for all prior spy and
N tau is roughly the weight uh a simple
equal to the weight of this in this
um
regime
all the frequencies which are the order
of between say 1 over 2N and 2 over n
this
foreign
what does fit mean compared to
memorization uh fit is just uh uh
predicting when uh accurately uh an
example in the data set
and memorization is predicting is
required to uh fit correctly something
in the data set when you cannot predict
it otherwise when it's a hard example
and we'll connect it in the next slide
we'll connect these two Notions
so is your second question over here
so uh the as I mentioned the style is
basically determined by the uh this
weight in the prior of this low uh this
low frequency significant but low
frequency elements um
and for example as I mentioned for zip
this ZIP distribution uh the style would
be roughly 1 over n log T which again uh
will uh will imply a relatively
significant price uh for not fitting
each each of the examples
let me just very briefly mention two
things about this result so we haven't
used it it's completely independent of
the function class f it doesn't depend
on the learning problem just says you
have to fit if you want to uh in this uh
if you want to uh be accurate and it
also uh so far this problem everything
was
um all the labels were perfect
uh they basically where this is no no
classification noise scenario but it
extends to the the situation uh with the
labels noise as long as sort of the
label You observe is most likely to be
correct the most likely one to be
correct
so this is what's about fitting let's
connect it to memorization uh just
recall very briefly this definition of
memorization is the difference between
the uh predicting sort of fitting the
example and uh predicting on it without
observing it
so now
the prediction predicting an example
without observing it is exactly the
uh the true accuracy of the algorithm so
if the problem is hard the true accuracy
has to be relatively not too high so
there are many examples which you cannot
predict well
so in order to fit those you will have
to memorize those so if you are if your
problem is sufficiently hard not not a
trivial problem if you if your problem
is
easy you don't need to memorize maybe
that's one way to think about it but if
it's not too easy you will not be able
to just guess everything so you'll need
to memorize in order to fit and we know
that fitting is important
yeah so that's that's the uh all that I
wanted to say so yes sorry
find it so if I understand it correctly
you say that rare examples are very
important to memorize because when they
appear in a testing phase the only way
to correctly label them is to have
memorized them uh right basically maybe
what I have to say is that
all rare examples some of them will be
useful some might be complete outliers
all rare examples are important to
memorize because you cannot distinguish
between those two but like you don't say
that memorizing rare examples will help
me predict other rare examples uh no in
fact kind of in this model I typically
assume
that they are sufficiently distinct in
any way the problem is they're all also
distinct from other ones that you know
about so you have to memorize
um and everything
yeah maybe that's something the point I
should emphasize here is that we're
showing that it's important to remember
the
the price uh the cost of memorization is
for all things you don't fit even if it
turned actually in actuality that
example is
some kind of outlier with zero frequency
or like close to
1 over N squared frequency
to my last question isn't the difference
between those two interpretations almost
nothing like the difference between you
have to memorize all the rare examples
even if they're outliers versus all the
rare examples but only the non-outliers
the outliers like back to my last
question the outliers are the things
that happen with probability much much
less than one over n so you're expecting
to see very few of them so no no not two
so what am I misunderstanding not
through a half of the population could
come from frequencies which are on the
order of one over N squared the overall
fraction of one over uh of populations
which are very rare complete outliers
could be very large you just can't the
point is with those you can't do
anything anyway
this it doesn't matter you won't be able
to predict on those well because you
will observe only a very small fraction
of all those of things which are all one
over n Square
the point of this model is that you will
still need to memorize them all
because there might be also a fraction
of a distribution imagine maybe my data
set I only have very few of them in my
data setup no you will have a lot of
them imagine that the
data distribution which is as follows it
has a bunch of subpopulations which are
on the frequency or one over n not a
bunch of risky n over two so half of the
entire population has has separations
with frequency one over n and the other
half is uh supervision with frequency
one over N squared right so in your data
set when you sample you will see half of
from each of those
and you need to memorize everything even
though half is actually useless and your
and the difference between the maybe
that that's where the interesting Parts
come from comes from is that
that's where the this translation Gap
will despite the generation gap will be
large
you will actually only be able to
predict well let's say this one half of
the data set but your training accuracy
is 100 so 100 and that's necessary
anyway in this term of time of which I
don't have too much let me go to
empirical validation
uh which is a little more uh easier and
fun so the goal of this empirical
validation is to
both to find these memorized examples
and understand their influence why are
they useful uh uh for Learning and what
is their effect on the accuracy of the
uh of the model on the training on the
tests
so again this is the definition of
memorization and we would like to be
able to estimate it except
it requires a training a model on all
the
uh while removing an example I so in
order to evaluate it on a memorization
for example we need to train at least
one model for every training example
which is prohibitively
um expensive even on small data set and
even if you're working for Google
um anyway so we weren't we cannot
estimate this value but using a
relatively simple
trick we have uh defined a proxy notion
which is very similar uh and the
difference is instead of evaluating this
memorization
um when you remove that single example
from the entire data set we measure the
expectation of the same notion when we
instead of measuring on the entire data
set we measure on a random subset of the
data set t
uh which is relatively large let's say
70 or 80 of the data set and we removed
that example from that just um
uh that subset
and the interesting part is that now to
evaluate this proxy which kind of feels
roughly the same and behaves very much I
believe the same
um
now this the to evaluated on all models
you basically need to only estimate off
uh measure of one models and that's just
some simple linearity of expectation
type of uh
analysis it's not so important for this
talk but it's a nice estimator not very
nice proxy
for some and as you'll see some matter
something very meaningful
so uh that's some these are some
examples of uh measuring this
memorization score for the class of
bobsled in imagenet and these are just
to be clear not cherry-picked we have a
website with a lot more images and just
uh sort of this is pretty much like the
first one that came so uh this is uh
High memorization estimates of the class
Bob set some of them you could see
aren't really bobsleds other are very
unique
images are actually a bobsled I believe
that's some kind of your box that the
other ones are this is also a view of a
box level hey and these are low
memorization these are uh things which
are have pretty much zero score they're
very easy they don't require memorizing
uh to be fit
so it seems to be doing the right thing
this estimator now the next question is
uh and our hypothesis is that the reason
why these are memorized is that they
help
predicting uh examples of from the same
subpopulation in the test set and the
question is can we how can we confirm
this and for this purpose we have this
defined this notion of influence which
is
and an influence of a
example I in the training data set on
the prediction at the example X Y any
example X Y is just the difference in
again in in the accuracy uh on that pair
X Y when uh the example I yes in the
entire data set and when the example is
excluded from this it's just the effect
of that single example on the prediction
accuracy at this pair X Y so we can now
discuss the effects of training examples
on predictions
uh we would like to estimate those
influences we cannot do it directly for
the same reason so we use just the same
trick we now Define it the same notion
just with respect to expectation
for of a random subset T which is
sufficiently large
and now we can run it again it's not so
cheap it still requires style training
thousands of models
so
this is just a bit of a distribution of
what kind of what we observe is uh by
measuring this that we find many pairs
where a single example has an influence
of just a prediction accuracy on another
uh in a training set has a large effect
on the
training accuracy uh
uh or an example in a test set and this
is the specific influences there from
0.2 to 0.6 and overall if you look at
the values above 0.2 you get or maybe
0.15 you get more than three percent of
the imagenet test set is affected by
such but these kind of very large
influences
so the overall effect is large but it
may be even more interesting is is to
look at actual examples of these high
influence and these are uh again from
uh imagenet uh this is the training
example which has the largest effect on
some Test example of the and this is the
class the specific one it's maybe not so
obvious but these are all kind of very
unusual example
relatively unusual and very similar to
each other
that's why they seem to memorize crime
some that's one and there are similar
things from a smaller cfr100 data set
also not so easy to see but they are
almost clearly very similar some some
we also easily find lots of duplicate
and some of these data sets using these
techniques but that's a separate
property of this so algorithms and these
are a specific influence values
memorization values doesn't matter
that's sort of the rough
uh some summary and there are many more
examples online if you like to browse
those
um
now let me discuss a little bit the
implications of these results and the
first one is for differential privacy
because we can very directly relate the
notion of memorization to differential
privacy and again this is the definition
of memorization and it looks at the
difference in predictions on some
example when you have an example uh and
in and you remove the example and if I
guess you saw you just saw a couple of
talks about differential privacy you
will realize that difference of privacy
relates these two quantities directly
and specifically we almost immediately
obtained that
the sort of the accuracy on the example
When You observe it is upper bounded by
e to the Epsilon times the accuracy on
the example when you cannot observe it
plus this Delta for an absolute Delta
depending Epsilon Del Delta differential
privacy which implies that memorization
score for an example is upper bounded
basically differential privacy limits
your ability to memorize directly in for
this particular notion of memory label
memorization
and now because it limits this quantity
we know that we can using the theorem
the type of theorems that I've mentioned
it will directly
um imply that
that in for these long tail
distributions differential privacy
differentially private algorithms cannot
be as accurate do have to pay some price
relative uh to non-differentially
private algorithm basically they require
more data to achieve the same actors
roughly which is not in any way
unexpected but uh this kind of shows it
uh formally Beyond sort of
there are other reasons we know there
are other problems but this is some
somewhat different type of phenomena for
what people have known uh in terms of
the costs of differential types
the other uh
implementation I would like to mention
is uh these so-called disparate effects
and there have been several Works uh
that have observed the following
phenomena yeah the first one is
they observe that if you
uh training differentially private
private model
on a population which has different
subgroups and particular particular
difference differently sites of groups
in their case and one happens to be
lighter skin the other uh is darker skin
uh image set then um
when you train with the fresh Enterprise
you experience a drop in accuracy and
this drop in accuracy seems to be larger
for uh this uh sort of less
well-represented group
so not not only both groups experience
the drop but the drop is larger so and
this day they refer this to this as
disparate effect of a certain technique
on on different subgroups in the
algorithm and there's a very similar uh
set of results from a work by hooker and
others who uh look at effects of
compression compression techniques where
you try to reduce the size of the model
that you have produced for example by
throwing away all the small weights uh
doing some kind of quantization
any any anything you want to do to to
uh to make the model smaller uh that
also naturally limits when you try to
compress the model it limits how well it
can memorize the data and what they have
observed in this context okay this is
really unreadable but what we look at is
uh effect the drop in accuracy as a
function uh of different different
classes and they see the different
classes
in the data set experience very
different drops in accuracy so it's not
uh the overall drop in accuracy is not
distributed kind of uniformly depends
very much on the class so it's also
again some a disparate effect on
different subpopulation or subgroups in
the data set and although this is just
uh there's nothing special it's just car
mirrors and peacocks and stuff like this
um
so the uh so both of these techniques
naturally restrict the memorization and
the results in this work show that
restricted memorization will have uh
will
cause sub-optimality and
they also show that this sub-optimality
depends on several several uh on three
different factors
uh this cost of normalization on
accuracy depends on first On sample size
which again if you have a smaller group
uh typically uh the overall weight of
the of this of these low frequency
elements will be higher so the cost of
normal memorizing will be higher uh it
will depend on subpopulation structure
it will depend on this prior that uh
frequencies that I've uh described
basically the more diverse in a way you
have the population the more likely that
the fraction of of this uh low frequency
Elements which are important is larger
so the cost of not memorizing is higher
and finally if the problem is the harder
the problem if the problem is hard for
predicting hard to predict is typically
it also increases the overall value of
this of this sub-optimality because
everything is multiplied by this
hardness to predict so if for example
your problem is
the problem on a subgroup is harder
among software is harder than it is on
the other for example you haven't
collected the right features or your
data on that subgroup is worse
uh then again the drop will be higher
because they'll be multiplied by
a bigger value will be multiplied uh
maybe it won't be higher in relative
terms but it will be higher in absolute
terms and that's what's being observed
uh so basically uh this this sort of
view uh uh this understanding in my mind
explains why we see these desperate
attacks
so that's uh all let me just uh briefly
mention some conclusions
I try to convince you that label
memorization is necessary for optimal
generalization
on long-tailed data which is the natural
kind of data
uh
this is not algorithm specific in any
way this is just a we sort of we started
looking this
because of deep learning but it is five
to all algorithms it is possible to
capture these things theoretically
although I believe more work is needed
to sort of incorporate and make up sort
of a more General
um uh learning theory model out of it
and as I mentioned it has interest
implications to uh effect on uh to
differential private eventually private
learning and also these disparate
attacks uh in terms of if you're
interested in learning more
the theoretical part of this paper has
appeared in stock a few years ago
experimental part in Europe's and the
result the experiments can be found in
this website the more and we also
include all the scores that are computed
so that you don't have to also burn more
icebergs if you want to play and a few
people have already made some good use
of of this data
and um
in terms of future work
I do hope it will inspire sort of more
work on more faithful models of learning
and that that sort of allow us to be
models in which Theory uh more closely
corresponds to observations empirical
observations and the second uh line for
future work of which of these already a
couple is is looking at other
applications of these estimators of
memorization score uh
and sort of
to gain insights into uh deep learning
more broadly thank you very much
thank you Vitaly I will I will like
abuse my Powers chair
um um to ask a vague and leading
question
um so so it seems like this work says in
a pretty strong sense you can't avoid
memorization if you're doing learning in
complex environments like you're going
to memorize
stuff
um and in thinking about sort of like
sort of like legal requirements of
privacy and most of our like you know
laws
don't cover machine learned models but
but it seems like your work says these
machine learned models sort of almost
like almost like integration
theoretically must memorize individual
points so like how do you interpret
these two things from of like of the
kind of implications of your work onto
these like legal privacy Notions
um thanks for the question I think that
maybe uh this is a little bit
too strong of an interpretation of this
it it shows that there is a cost to not
memorizing it doesn't mean that you
cannot learn without memorizing it just
means that if you really want to be the
top of the at the benchmarks uh you
really want to beat everybody else then
you have to memorize uh and the more
data you have the smaller the effect the
cost is and in practice
if especially if you're a company with
lots of devices and lots of data that in
fact could be essentially negligible you
can I don't think it's impossible to
reconcile privacy uh and
accuracy it's just that there is this
cost
uh it will be more significant when you
have less data
and
um so yeah maybe the maybe the
there are some interesting questions
especially when you consider desperate
effects because these things do affect
more supervision which have even fewer
data and for these superflation maybe
there is an inherent trade-off between
privacy and accuracy that you they can
achieve
um
that is maybe for the people of this
Workshop too to discuss much more than
uh for me but but I think overall it the
message is not so bad that we cannot
learn it's just there are trade-offs and
they get better if you have lots of them
thank you
I'll now share the mic oh my gosh
somebody let's hear from a voice we
haven't heard before
hi thank you for the great talk so uh if
we have sub populations where you know
we don't have sufficient data is there
any benefit to creating synthetic data
you know by perturbing and sort of
learning from that so we're not directly
memorizing
um
the question I think first of all uh
there are many uh
different ways to improve and and in
general if you can improve your accuracy
by perturbing data creating some kind of
synthetic data or these kind of uh date
doing some kind of data augmentation
technique you should be doing this there
is if there is no harm and maybe even
more extensively if you have a little
data for some subgroup uh what this work
shows is there are some inherent
limitations which no learning algorithm
can resolve it's just you just won't be
able to tell
in some rare things and others so yeah
so maybe the question you should be
doing what you're doing but it's not
that but not all problems can be solved
by
um data augmentation techniques
um so I guess I wanted to ask so the
work shows that label memorization is
necessary is there a sense in which
memorization is sufficient to have good
error for these problems or sort of like
if you memorize and maybe satisfy some
other simple property then in this
learning setting where you have these
Zips distributions
um you'll have reasonable
um
a good question uh I certainly the work
doesn't say anything and and we
there is there is much more to learning
than memorization in in a way this is
this work is about
saying that memorization is important
it's not that the other things are
unimportant in fact balancing capacity
and kind of uh if it could be important
for some parts of the data it's I decide
I don't think uh that there are any
implications as work that's that's
but that's enough we do need to find
good representations for that that's
just numbers we know that just say
nearest neighbor will not do well on uh
even in these problems
okay so for now for this theory model
where you have a discrete Set uh of just
two points yes that's just memorization
there is nothing else you need because
okay
sorry even that is not accurate if you
it is still question what do you assume
about the learning the
um
the function class if you don't assume
anything about the function class let's
say that all labels are independent
then it boils down to just memorizing
because there is no relationship but if
there is some structure you can still
learn better if you exploit the
structure labels
okay so I know there were more more
hands but I think in the interest of
time
um let's save those questions for tea
time and let's think like Avatar again
for his
thank you
so we have Tino upstairs on the second
floor into